hey this is press tow
Walker this video features two counting
problems and tricks you should
know problem one in a singles tennis
tournament there are 100 players each
match pairs two players the winner
advances and the loser is eliminated
assuming a minimum number of
buys these are games in which a player
automatically advances due to no
opponent how many matches are needed to
determine a tournament
winner this problem is asked in many
many different contexts it was once
asked on the SAT it was asked as an
Olympiad qualifier I've seen it in many
many test it's a problem that you should
know how to
solve problem
two the putam competition is an annual
exam for undergraduate students in the
United States and can Canada there are 3
hours to solve six problems for an
average of 30 minutes per problem and
then there are another 3 hours to solve
another six problems for a total of six
hours for 12 questions each question is
worth 10 points for a maximum of 120
points but the average or median score
is about one point even though the
students taking the competition are
exceptional at math
today's video is about a 1985 puam
question
A1 calculate the number of ordered
triples A1 comma A2 comma A3 such that
their Union is the integers from 1 to 10
and their intersection is the empty set
express your answer in the form 2 to the
a multiplied by 3 to the B multiplied by
5 to the C multiplied by 7 to the D
where a b c and d are non- negative
integers pause the video if you'd like
to give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve these
[Music]
problems let's solve problem one I'll
first illustrate the long way to solve
this
in which you count the number of matches
that are played round by round so there
are 100 players so we'll count the
number of matches and the number of
players left in each round in the first
round 100 players can be paired into 50
different
matches 50 of the players will be
eliminated so 100 minus 50 will leave 50
players the remaining 50 players can be
paired up into 50 over2 which equals
equal 25
matches each of these matches will have
one player eliminated so 25 players will
be eliminated and that means 50us 25
equals 25 players left how many matches
will be played in the next round 25 is
an odd number so we can only get up to
24 players that are paired so 24 players
can be paired into 12 matches in these
12 matches exactly one player will be
eliminated in each match so then 12
players will be eliminated the number of
players left will be 25- 12 which equals
13 again we have an odd number so we can
pair up 12 of the 13 so that will be
into six different matches now six
players will be eliminated so then 13
minus 6 will leave seven players left we
can now have six of the players paired
up into three matches three players will
be eliminated 7 - 3 equal 4 we can now
pair up these four players into two
matches this will leave two players left
finally the two players play in the
championship game and exactly one player
will be left that's the champion so the
total number of matches played is the
sum of the matches in this column so we
take 50 + 25 + 12 + 6 + 3 + 2 + 1 and
that is 99 matches and that is the
answer but this is the long way to do it
we could actually solve it in a very
short way using logical thinking so
here's how it works in every match
exactly one player loses and gets
eliminated there is one champion who
never loses and the other 99 players who
get
eliminated for 99 players to be
eliminated there must be 99 matches
therefore there are 99 matches to
determine the winner the great thing
about this solution is you can even
generalize if there's a single
elimination tournament with n players
then you will need n minus one matches
what a wonderful
trick now let's solve problem
two let's work through it step by step
suppose we have a number from the
integers going from 1 to 10 we need to
assign this number to A1 or A2 or A3 or
some combination of these
sets so this number could be in set A1
or not in set A1 it could be in set A2
or not in set A2 it could be in set A3
or not in set A3 so there are two
choices for the first set two choices
for the second set and two choices for
the third set we multiply these together
to get 2 ^ 3 which equals eight
possibilities but we need to remove some
of the
possibilities we know we can't have X in
all three sets because the intersection
needs to be the empty set so we subtract
out one
possibility we also subtract out the
possibility that X is not in A1 A2 or A3
because we need it to be in one of the
three sets so that their Union is all of
the numbers going from 1 to 10 so we
subtract two possibilities from eight
and that gives us six
possibilities now there's a nice way to
visualize this let's say we have three
sets A1 A2 and
A3 normally we would draw The Logical
relationships between these three sets
as follows but we want the intersection
of all three sets to be the empty set so
this region where all three circles
intersects needs to be the empty set so
we'll just slightly redraw this diagram
so that region doesn't exist we'll pull
these cires CES apart and now the
circles just intersect at a point and
there's nothing in the interior between
all three circles so how many regions
are there we have one region which is A1
- A2 - A3 another region is A2 - A1 - A3
a third region is A3 - A1 - A2 then we
have the intersection of A1 and A2 the
intersection of A1 and A3 and the
intersection of A2 and A3 three this
makes for a total of six regions so now
let's solve the
problem the number of ordered triples A1
A2 A3 is equal to the number of ways to
partition the whole numbers from one to
10 into six disjoint
subsets there are six possibilities for
each of the 10 numbers meaning 6 to ^ of
possibilities 6 is equal to 2 * 3 so
that gives us 6 ^ 10 is equal to 2 ^ 10
* 3 ^ 10 and that's the
answer if you like this video you may
also like some of the other puam
competition questions I've covered over
the years there are links to each of
these in the video
description do you have a favorite Plum
competition question that I haven't
covered yet please let us know in a
comment or by sending me an email I
definitely consider all interesting
problem suggestions
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind and your decisions where
we solve The World's problems one video
at a
time